this is one of Europe's biggest aluminum
producers but its days could be numbered
Greek heavy industry will receive
electricity at fixed prices for a few
more days on January the 1st contracts
expire and prices will float at Market
rates of more than 300 per megawatt hour
compared to half that in northern Europe
which is being subsidized
this plant may have to close unless the
government steps in
the industry Association says Factory
closures would also be a setback for the
fight against climate change if we lose
Metals in Europe these metals are going
to be imported
the imported Metals will be produced
mostly by countries
that use coal as a fuel
some use oil
and definitely they have a much heavier
footprint than European companies that's
why for the self-sufficiency of Europe
and for the global decarbonization we
must save the European Metals industry
aluminum smelting requires vast
quantities of electricity it's only
profitable if the power is cheap and the
Ukraine war has caused the prices of
coal oil and gas to soar a quarter of a
million people working at non-ferrous
Metals plants across Europe are at risk
of losing their jobs
higher energy costs are having a ripple
effect many butcheries which depend on
refrigeration are being forced to shut
their doors Andreas nyotis says
electricity costs have doubled this year
we're talking about small family
businesses here we try to keep our costs
low so that we can stay open our last
electricity bill was more than nine
thousand dollars and we paid six
thousand dollars the government subsidy
certainly helped profit margin to tiny
but we are viable the question is how
long will the subsidy last
Agriculture and transport costs are also
up more industries that depend on
government support the government is
spending more than five billion dollars
subsidizing electricity bills for
households and businesses this year and
energy producers are being forced to
spend twice that amount from their
excess profits all of that money
together represents as much income as
Greece made this year from tourism its
primary industry so even if individual
Enterprises survive the energy crisis
Greece as a whole is losing enormous
amounts of money
the Ukraine war is speeding up
investment in renewable energy but for
now governments are forced to offer
fossil fuel subsidies to preserve jobs
and livelihoods John saropoulos Al
Jazeera Athens